you know that teachers they're not
transfing the kids that's a right-wing
crazy conspiracy theory that's your wild
wacky Uncle who watches too much
conservative media he thinks that that's
happening and the non-binary transgender
Texas Middle School teachers who are
transiting the kids in the classroom
they're very upset that you're talking
about this
so the conversation I talked about in my
last video is a lot like a lot of the
conversations I have about queerness and
transness with my kids
um because I work in a conservative area
and I'm an out non-binary trans teacher
I have to tread very lightly for fear of
losing my job and so a lot of times I
put it in terms of hypotheticals with
the kids I say oh some people like to
use this when I talk about my title mix
I say oh it's just a third alternative
to Mr Miz that some people like to use
I let them kind of draw their own
conclusions when it comes back to me
while also keeping it General enough to
not bring the heat on myself
but she doesn't obviously she doesn't
let them draw the right conclusions this
is what the libs always say
and we say we we don't teach students
what to think we just teach them how to
think
but if if a teacher instructs her
students to address her as mix rather
than Mrs or Miss
you are teaching your student what to
think if you tell your students then mix
this made-up word referring to a fake
concept
you say mix is a third option for people
who aren't totally male aren't totally
female
then what you are telling them is
there is a third option that there are
people who aren't totally male and
aren't totally female and that's false
that's not true and this teacher should
lose her job I have nothing against this
teacher in personally she seems
I don't know I was going to say she
seems like a nice person I'm not totally
convinced of that but
I love her in as much as I love any
other child of God but
people who are this confused about basic
tenets of reality
not only have no right to to teach
children but
really we have an obligation to prevent
them from teaching our children if you
send your kid to this teacher's
classroom
that teacher is going to be taught a lot
of lies that teachers education is not
going to be well served so the next
Frontier for conservatives is how do we
prevent these people from teaching
because I promise you if that teacher
were fired for not understanding basic
aspects of reality which is kind of the
first job requirement of a teacher is
you got to understand basic stuff so
that you can impart that wisdom to
students
but if this teacher were fired
there would be some discrimination
lawsuit because of the stupid Bostock
decision from the Supreme Court thank
you justice Gorsuch you you have people
interpreting civil rights protections on
the basis of sex as civil rights
protections on the basis of gender
identity which ironically totally
undercuts civil rights protections on
the basis of sex
and this teacher would probably get a
huge payout and probably be able to keep
her job
that we need to change that law we
cannot
have a serious sane flourishing country
in which the teachers are that lady
now maybe if she changes her mind comes
back to reality then she can go back
into the classroom but as long as she is
calling herself mix
as long as she identifies as trans pans
thank you ma'am
she cannot be permitted to teach our
kids forget about
telling the the five-year-olds I guess
she's a middle school teacher so telling
the 11 year olds that they ought to go
on puberty blockers and cut off their
genitals or whatever forget that
just teaching them anything at all her
world view is deeply wrong
and so whatever she teaches if it in any
way touches on these delusions that she
has
that teaching is going to be wrong
and I know that in our modern culture we
focus on the transgender identifying
people as the only victims in the world
and even when they're committing crimes
they're actually the victims but
students have the right to an education
taxpayers have the right to
as they fund schools fun schools that
are teaching kids real things parents
have the right to send their kids to go
get a real education
transgender identifying people do not
have any right to the transgender
identity because that identity isn't
real
it's imaginary
and you don't have a right to things
that are false and imaginary and wrong
you obviously don't have a right to
things that are wrong that's why it's
called a right
but you're seeing this spread everywhere
there's a new bill in America's Top Hat
up in Canada that would
in certain areas outlaw
transphobia
firstly it enables the Attorney General
to create a 2s LGBT Qi plus Community
safety zone to prohibit within a hundred
meters of the property any homophobic
transphobic Act of intimidation threat
offensive threats offensive remarks
protest disturbance and distribution of
hate propaganda within the meaning of
the criminal code it also comes with it
a penalty of twenty five thousand
dollars if prosecuted successfully
so if you're
if you're in one of the
anti-free speech zones if you're in one
of forget even anti-free speech if
you're in one of the
transgender protection zones which I'm
sure they're going to make the whole
country
and you say
[Music]
women are real and men are not them
you'd be fine twenty five thousand
dollars
according to this bill
come into a Locale near you
what's the direction of our country we
can point we say that's crazy what's
happening in Canada that's crazy what's
happening in the Netherlands that's
crazy what's happening in Belgium I
think of on especially these issues of
life and identity and culture
the assisted suicide the abortion the
tranzing of everybody you we look at
these other countries we say wow we'll
never get that far well that's the
direction we're going in
how did how is Joe Biden the worst
president than Obama
is that's the way the wind is blowing
from the powerful people
you're seeing it and you're seeing
increasing violence on the streets
I I see it because I give these speeches
and I go to I was just in Buffalo I was
just in Purdue
there was an antifa presence there
antifa they're anti-fascists they're
really Communists and anarchists and
they show up and they threaten political
violence they threaten terrorism to
attack civilians in the furtherance of a
political ideology and
uh they they show up and they scream
they're so unlikable that they've
actually made enemies of prominent
liberals there was a video that went
around I I just adore this video it's
Michael Rapaport who is a
very radical leftist comedian and he
hates Trump and he hates conservatives
and he's a loudmouth about everything
but Michael Rapaport got into a fight
with antifa that became very vulgar very
fast
nobody's going anywhere you don't
think you are don't make the mistake
[Music]
why are you wearing a mask
elaborate on your feelings about the day
it's fantastic it's a fantastic day
yeah
do you want do you want to walk around
the corner with me
all right that's what I thought that's
what I thought if not come walk around
the corner with me
yeah I'm trying to get you to come see
me I'll come around the corner
degrees
I bring up the clip not only because
it's very very funny to watch two
leftists attack each other I look at it
as sort of the Iraq Iran War you know I
just want both sides to lose
but
to show you the state of of political
debate in America right now this is
pretty much where we're at
yeah you want to walk around the corner
what so that I can blank your blank yeah
so that you can blank my blank and then
I'm gonna blank your blank and then we
you can fill in the blanks or probably
it's wiser at Art to fill in the blanks
that's where we're at that's the level
of debate right now
it's it's not all that much different in
the US Congress compared to what this is
we're not exactly living in the 19th
century Lincoln Douglas style debates
here and we are seeing an increase in
political violence
I've seen it just myself I Tour all over
the country giving speeches I've done it
now for what six seven years and you can
see it increasing tensions are very very
hot and the reason it's hot was actually
the topic of my speech last night at UNC
Greensboro
which is that
is one of the real dangers of
transgenderism the real danger of
transgenderism well there's a lot of it
one you're castrating it's little kids
that's horrible and you're you're
encouraging pathologies that are
associated with suicidality that's awful
and you know you but the real Ultimate
problem is that it's divorced from
reality and when you divorce your
political actions from reality
everything stops making sense
it's not just that you'll confine it to
this one area on sexual policy or on
bathrooms or on no it all stops making
sense because when you
contradict reality what you're saying is
the universe is not really intelligible
reason has no place in our political
debates all that matters is my
willfulness if I say that I'm a woman
well dagnabbit I am a woman and you can
make all the reasoned arguments you want
as to why I can't go into the women's
bathroom but I'm going in that's my
politics
it all breaks down to the point that you
have criminals camping out in law
enforcement buildings in the police
station and the police aren't going to
do anything about it
because
the law the reason the intelligibility
of the universe it all falls apart and
that's where we are
the when this is this is the whole
conclusion of 1984 by George Orwell I
know it's invoked a lot but it's invoked
a lot for a reason because it was
prophetic
if the party can get you to say that two
plus two equals five and especially if
they can get you to believe that two
plus two equals five and our ruling
party has gotten a lot of our people
to believe that two plus two equals five
then they can do anything at all
and Justice be damned they'll go after
their enemies they'll defend their
friends they will persecute pro-life
fathers they'll let gangsters who maraud
all over the country totally off the
hook
now the rest of the show continues now
we've got the memoriam segmentum this is
the most important time of the day when
I get to hear from you and I insisted to
Mr Davies I said Mr Davies I know we're
on the road I know it's hard
but I want my iPad and I want to talk to
the members of the Inner Circle if
you're not a member yet go to
dailywire.com Knowles promo code nulls
get two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over at the member block
[Music]